interesting poll came out from the good folks
over at pew they're doing a ton of
research over there
and America and over we don't think
america's number one in the great
numbers that we used the let's look at
some info here
so the study found that just 28 percent
believe that the US
stands above all other countries in the
world which is compared to 38 percent
back in 2000 I have had a 10 percent
drop in just a couple here
fifty-eight percent say it's one of the
greatest countries in the world along
with some others
and 12 percent say that there are other
countries that are better
some fifty-two percent said america
stood about the others in 2011
that had dropped to thirty seven-percent
I just a couple other little points
information for your
at they also found that Americans 18 to
29 or at the bottom up those who view
the nation
as standing alone in greatness I just 15
percent
have those under 30 express that you
today I went down
27 percent just a couple years ago
thanks let's start here
why is it that republicans seem to love
America
more even though their numbers are
dropping and actually dropped more
then Democrats in the last couple years
why to republicans love this country
more
then you crazy democrats what's going on
at the they don't love it more than just
like them
wave the flag more yeah I mean it I had
they have nothing to do with wood
what they were really thinking that they
are just you know who the hell cares
whose number one anyway every book on
abortion what we're number one in
keeping our own citizens in prison and
how was your age and that's what I
thought I'd let me know
arriving I'm flag crime rates murder
rate I'm sure all
BBC right yeah they are being yeah
carbon emissions that they are gonna go
there and then it may not be true now
yeah and shower
i mean but you know it's all in the
people who are more waving flag
and you know that the heart is the
longest time just you know our
are really don't understand what's going
on in this country I'll
really get the full picture you know
there's the defective is what they are
still affected YES on weekends so is
there some
is there some weird thing like I love
this country I think I believe in
American exceptionalism cuz we had
people from
all over the world come here to try to
make a better life
but the result so critical the country's
because I love it so I think the days or
to view it as
if you're critical they look at people
that are critical of our policies and
think what you look like what we are
trash it yeah time exceptionalism anyway
what I mean that to me is is it that
that doesn't have a good thing the good
Fig
well remember during the election the
first time in 2008 they asked Obama if
you believe in American exceptionalism
and he said I believe in it just as
Greeks probably good believe in Greek
exceptionalism
the only difference is we're a nation
that made up your earlier emigrates
so I do think there is something special
there well I think there's a man there's
also a fine line between sort of
patriotism and nationalism
I miss Agnes is always the fine line
that I think some in this country the
lab
I mean the ride I've sorta veer too far
to the side which is
you know their I where all I hope
Patriots you know i mean in this country
is incredibly
exception on a in the sense that it's
built by immigrants that you have the
freedom to criticize that we can make a
show like this
those things are all pretty
extraordinary and and we should be
critical because that is what our role
in my bed
hard right yet hope that the whole
hearted as a whole you know they they
don't they don't
they think it in the just by watching it
being critical event is what makes it so
great that they are right that you know
and
and also with those guys who were saying
you know America love it or leave it
who also right below that bumper sticker
have those nudie mud flaps
yeah are you really gonna listen to
their
if the live there well now we've lost
our viewer in Kentucky I'll
handjob do you think there's a danger
though for it for the young people that
their numbers are pretty loading is a
weird danger for them not to think
America's number one like I remember
going up it was so obvious America's
number one you can do anything you want
et cetera et cetera and then ira kid no
but that you when you grow up with at
least that idea
there's I think there's something good
about that you think that the country
living in his number one that you can't
do something you can just
is that just is that is childish now and
I'll
I don't feel that it's important to rank
yeah the country I think it's important
to
10 build a good country be good citizen
and question things and make things
better idea
really think it's important where you
rank internationally i think thats like
like the Olympic break my heart just
ESPN Inc
a you know the world I think that
special that in
in this country if you work really hard
I mean it helps to be from a certain
you know economic back on the beginning
with work really hard you can make
something really special when you look
at
the impact that you know even you know
immigrants are made and in
in the taxi and especially in Silicon
Valley people just recently come to this
country what they've done and how
transformative
that's what's really special so to me
like the fact that
many kids don't think that we're number
one that doesn't matter so much but
I wouldn't want the member to lose the
fact that if you work really really hard
you can do something really special in
transforming I think the part iv:
pardo the problem what happen in America
before as is that
American Dream get skewed where you
think if I'm
I might get lucky and become a
millionaire strike oil in the office and
on millionaire and that ideas like I can
be
as rich as anybody else like I can be
whoever it is you on moscow ever it is
but like that reality is you can't be
that unless you're willing to dedicate
so much of your time energy
and doing something and it's not all
about money yeah it's not about money
and I and i really
I hope the stress can be taken off that
it has to do with contributing
young it doesn't have to do with getting
Mia you know what you did not like
Iran's books did you I didn't read them
but I'd rather
up